[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about someone who is
when you think about it actually one of
the most mysterious characters in the
seven deadly sins she is believed to be
the greatest mage in all of Britannia
and she is also the boar's sin of
gluttony but despite being one of the
seven deadly sins there is still so much
that we don't know about Merlin we have
gotten some brief glimpses into her past
and the manga has given us some major
clues recently about the fact that
Merlin is deliberately hiding certain
critical information about the previous
holy war
we have also gotten clues that suggest
that Merlin has a secret plan that she
has been putting into motion for a very
long time and in this video I will be
deciphering the clues in order to
explain what I think Merlin is hiding
and what I think she is secretly
planning for the future and yes this is
related to the recent bombshell
revelations that we have gotten about
esta rosa true identity a theory that I
had formulated in a previous video which
was then confirmed to be true in the
manga which was crazy if you like the
seven deadly sins content on this
channel and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell I actually made a poll on the anime
uproar Twitter so you guys can vote for
which seven deadly sins video you want
to see next here on the channel be sure
to check us out on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar and cast your vote in
the poll naturally this video will
contain the manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution if you haven't read
the manga and you've only seen the anime
some of this information will definitely
be new to you I strongly suggest reading
the manga it is available legally
through crunchy rolls manga section they
don't sponsor me or anything that's just
a site that I use so what do we know
about Merlin here is the official story
that we have so far although keep in
mind that recently we've been finding
out a lot about memories being
manipulated so the official story may
not be the full story despite looking
like a young woman of about 30
Merlin is actually over 3,000 years old
and her true name is not Merlin at all
she only uses this name because humans
cannot pronounce her true name Merlin
was born in beli allowin a city once
known as the capital of the Wizards
sometimes translated as the capital of
the sages her birth was a monumental
occasion as she was apparently born with
infinite magic aka with the ability
called
infinity the warring goddess and demon
clans both tried to get Merlin to come
over to their side during the previous
holy war and they each offered secret
magical knowledge in return for her
support but rather than picking either
side Merlin took advantage of the offers
by both sides the demon king gave her
knowledge about the dark secrets of the
demon realm and made her immune to the
brainwashing and possession techniques
of the goddess clan the supreme deity
gave her the ability to protect herself
against the dark curses used by the
demons
according to the official info that we
have right now the rulers of the goddess
and demon clans were so angry that
Merlin tricked them in order to gain
knowledge from both sides that they
destroyed the entire city of Belaya
Luwin but Merlin managed to escape the
destruction and became the only known
survivor from the capital of the Wizards
it is believed that this incident is why
Merlin is known as the Boursin of
gluttony she couldn't say no to one side
or the other she just couldn't get
enough so she's a glutton for knowledge
it is worth noting that due to some
confusion with the translation many
people believe that Merlin is actually
the daughter of the demon king and the
supreme deity however unless some memory
manipulation has been going on again
this wouldn't make sense since in
chapter 249 we learned that Merlin can't
be the daughter of the demon king and
the supreme deity because it was only
after she was born and rumors spread
about her ability to use infinite magic
that the demon king and the supreme
deity took an interest in her also in
chapter 200
forty-three we actually briefly see
Merlin's father who at the time was the
only man aside from Ellie Otis who had
entered purgatory however a minute in
the outside world is equivalent to a
year in purgatory and when Merlin's
father returned he was an old decrepit
man
so unless all of this information that
we have about her father is false Merlin
is not the daughter of the demon king
and the supreme deity there are a few
other things that we know about Merlin's
past Merlin was apparently trained in
the magical arts by both her father and
the original Golder the same powerful
wizard who was at one point a member of
the ten commandments and who created the
dalgo third a current gold sin of lust
this connection between Gotha and Merlin
is very important to remember because
Gotha is the one who succeeded in ending
the holy war 3,000 years ago by
manipulating the memories of mile AKA
esta rosa and everyone who knew him but
of course there is one person whose
memories the original goal thir likely
would not have manipulated and that
person is Merlin because don't forget
that she had already gained by this
point immunity from brainwashing from
the demon king himself so it is possible
that Merlin has known the truth this
entire time both about mile and about
how the first holy war ended while he
was training her the original go thirst
aided that Merlin had potential beyond
even his own understanding which means
that Merlin's power could one day
surpass the power of original Gotha
another interesting fact that we know
about Merlin is that 3,000 years ago she
was very close to the original goddess
Elizabeth and she called her big sis on
top of that we know that Merlin has a
true form and in this form a Merlin
looks like a small girl
meaning that Merlin is essentially a
secret lolly now the question is why
does Merlin look like this in her
original form
Merlin's true race continues to be a
major unsolved mystery in the series and
my good friend Briggs from all day anime
made an entire video talking about
Merlin's
so I will link that video in the
description feel free to check it out we
can assume that Merlin is neither a pure
goddess nor a pure demon because neither
the demon king nor the supreme deity
knew about her until they heard the
rumors about her power we can also
assume that she is not human because
humans are not capable of pronouncing
her true name so that it wouldn't make
sense for Merlin to be a human herself
could she be some type of very and that
is why she looks like a child in her
true form that might make sense but back
when we actually saw Merlin's father it
was clear that he looked like an adult
so was he also transformed at that point
or is Merlin actually part of some
completely different and unknown race
these and many other questions about
Marilyn still remain a mystery but this
much is clear
Merlin has been keeping secrets I am
sure that there is more to Merlin's
relationship with the original golfer
and it is not a coincidence that Gotha
was both Merlin's teacher and the one
who manipulated everyone's memories in
order to end the holy war Merlin who has
immunity from being brainwashed likely
knew exactly what happened with Maya and
the holy war this entire time but she
kept much of it hidden and I believe
that Merlin also has a secret plan for
the future a plan that centers around
King Arthur of Camelot
even though Arthur appears to have died
in the manga let's be real death has
never stopped characters in the seven
deadly sins from coming back I mean even
Zara's came back to life I mean c'mon
now the real question is why does Merlin
care so much about Arthur in particular
and how does he fit into her secret plan
Merlin says that Arthur is someone who
will one day rule britannia because he
was chosen by the holy sword Excalibur
Excalibur is unique because it gives off
a strange energy that is neither from
the goddess or the demon clan and the
sword contains within it the souls of
its previous owners
the previous owners are the former
heroes of Britannia
have apparently chosen Arthur to become
a king among kings one of the reasons
why I'm sure that we haven't seen the
last of Arthur and the reason why I
think that Merlin has a secret plan
involving Arthur that has been in motion
for a very long time is that the entire
story of the seven deadly sins is
heavily inspired by Arthur Ian's legend
meliodas
Merlin colder bond Leona's Camelot and
so many other names of people and places
in the seventh of the Sense story are
direct references to the names of people
and places in Arthurian legend and of
course King Arthur Pendragon and the
legendary sword Excalibur are the focal
point of the entire legend the name
itself Arthurian legend comes from King
Arthur because he is the main character
so it only makes sense that in a story
so heavily inspired by Arthur Ian's
legend King Arthur will eventually play
an important role in our 13 legend
Merlin is the wizard who cleverly plans
and executes Arthur's ascension to the
throne of Britain and then serves as his
mentor so it is pretty clear that Merlin
has a plan which involves Arthur
becoming the king among kings and the
ruler of all of Britannia however at
this point in the story it seems
impossible to even imagine Arthur's
power rivaling the power of someone like
Mel Yoda's or the demon king so what is
Merlin's plan
how does she plan to make Arthur a key
player well for one I think that we
still haven't even come close to
discovering the full power of Excalibur
and I think that this legendary sword
and the souls of the former heroes of
Britannia that are contained within it
is going to play an essential role later
on in the story
another major clue comes from the intro
sequence that we have seen at the
beginning of every anime episode so far
the narrator tells us that this is a
tale from ancient times when the human
and non-human worlds had not yet split
the holy wars have been repeating
themselves throughout Britannia history
and no one seemed to know why they broke
out and how to stop them until now that
Melly Otis and the 7th of these sins are
on the case so to speak
so what does this tell us it tells us
that at some point in the future the
human realm is likely going to be
separated from the other realms such as
the demon realm perhaps the only way to
stop these holy wars from occurring in
the future will be to use incredibly
powerful magic to seal away the races
within their own separate realms where
they can exist without fighting each
other if this is the way that the seven
deadly story is going to end with the
human realm being separated from the
other realms in order to prevent more
death and suffering then I believe that
Arthur and Excalibur will play a key
role in all of this and beyond that I
think that golfer and the original gold
are going to play an important role as
well we know from what the demons tell
us after they are released from the
coffin of eternal darkness that
Britannia in the present era has far
less magic than Britannia from 3,000
years ago so we can only imagine what
kind of power Merlin and the original
goal thir had at their disposal back
before the last holy war as I said
earlier I believe that there is more to
the relationship between Merlin and the
original goal than we are aware of right
now well we know that goal thir was
Merlin's teacher and that he was
insanely powerful to the point that he
was able to end the entire holy war by
manipulating everyone's memories of my
hell we also know one other bit of
information
Gotha the wizard made goal third a doll
to look like his lover but because he
didn't want to have sexual desires for
the doll Golder made him have masculine
rather than feminine physical features
this means that goal third the doll
would bear some resemblance to the
Wizards lover although they would not
look exactly the same we are not sure
what happened to the woman that the
original Goldar loved but in my personal
opinion the only other character who
resembles the doll go thir in any
significant way is Merlin so could it be
that this entire time Merlin has been
hiding that she is not only the student
but also the lover of the original Gotha
and together they have been executing a
secret plan to finally put an end to the
wars between the different races after
all it was Merlin who gave the doll go
through his enchanted armor so did she
do it to make sure that no one else
would notice the resemblance between her
and goal third a doll will Merlin use
ancient magic and the power of Excalibur
to seal away two different races within
their own realms in order to stop the
conflict once and for all and is that
how we will eventually get from the
magical world of ancient Britannia to
our own modern world which has no magic
or perhaps Merlin is not Golders lover
but is connected to him in some other
way
maybe original goal Thurs lover was
Merlin's mother and Merlin simply looks
like her mother
in fact according to Arthur T and legend
the wizard Merlin was the son of a
mortal woman and an incubus which is a
male demon so could that be a clue that
Merlin will turn out to be the daughter
of a human woman and the demon Golder
this would explain why Merlin has such
exceptional magic since original goal
there was an incredibly powerful wizard
but this wouldn't explain why we saw a
glimpse of Merlin's father as he entered
purgatory since that man was clearly not
go through it could be another trick or
mind manipulation or that man could
really be Merlin's father we'll have to
wait and find out at this point we just
can't know for sure but I am willing to
bet that we are going to learn a lot
more about Merlin's past and her
relationship with original Golder in the
coming chapters I also predict that King
Arthur and Excalibur will play a major
role in the future and that Merlin has a
secret plan to use Arthur and Excalibur
to put an end to the holy wars once and
for all let me know what you guys think
do you agree that Merlin's hidden past
will come into play in the story and
what do you think is her real connection
to the wizard Golder also what role do
you think that Arthur and Excalibur are
going to play in the future give me your
thoughts down in the comments or you can
hit me up on social media on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar if you enjoy
the seven deadly sins content on this
channel and you want to see more you can
let me know by leaving a like and of
course if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell as always thank you
guys so much for watching and thanks for
all your support on the Esther osa mile
video it's crazy how that theory turned
out to be confirmed in the very next
chapter and until next time see our
space cowboys
[Music]
you